pas de détour n'oubliez pas ce qu'on
vient chercher et ne fait confiance à
personne
qu'est ce que c'est terre des moussons
tes parents qui appartient ce bébé un
bébé petit moquette
[Musique]
impressionnant toi tu va m'être utile
petit résumé de la situation
je m'appelle rail à notre pays est en
guerre depuis toujours notre peuple ne
parvient pas à s'entendre
ma fille je veux croire que l'esprit de
commandera et toujours la roue mais
quelqu'un doit faire le premier pas pour
instaurer enfin la paix nous devons
retrouver le dernier dragon
si vous avez l'intention d'aller broyer
le trône
je suis prêt en avant
il faudra être très prudent nous ne
sommes pas les seuls sur le coup
ces années de recherche pourvu que ce
soit bien là
dissoudre
qui a parlé nous avons vraiment besoin
de vous je vais être honnête avec toi
suis pas comme qui dirait le meilleur
des dragons mais tu connais le travail
de groupe avec ce camarade de classe qui
n'affichent pas une et qui à l'arrivée
obtient la même d'autre que toi on est
mort
vous allez me suivre toit et la pierre
de dragon mon épée nous dit qu'elle
n'est pas d'accord
le monde sa magie
la confiance a disparu
peut-être que le monde va mal parce que
on se doit de faire le premier pas
puis métamorphoser les dragons peuvent
faire ça et regarde tu fais tout près de
la tête ça va accélérer la digestion
c'est bien